this is not for the faint of heart
offering a one thousand seven hundred
fifty meter long descent over the Han
Dinah's leg in Wales
this is Europe's longest zipline
riders travel at about 100 km/h and
experience the feeling of traveling at
high speed with no brakes brilliant best
feeling ever
it's amazing as well yeah it's like
you're flying basically like doing what
I Superman
I'm very what a rush what a rush
fantastic yeah I want to go again Dylan
Hughes lives near the Snowdonia National
Park he can barely wait to try the
zipline I've been looking forward for
about four months since they've started
building the ship boy I'm quite nervous
at the moment shaking and I'm expecting
a lot of adrenaline and excitement
he learns the art of flying by wire on
this shorter 500 meter course
breaking is only possible when the
writer sticks his or her arms out
heavier writers tend to reach the end of
the course faster
absolutely fantastic fantastic I'm gonna
go again
the ride starts at the top of the
mountain instructor Sean Taylor
accompanies the participants to the
launch point the quarry at its own
hospital and the hospital was pale the
first the zipline is located in an
unused part of a quarry that has been in
operation since the mid 19th century
setting up the course cost six hundred
thousand euros the concept is a journey
I think you've all seen automatic this
area is I don't think there's anywhere
in Europe that's got what we've got here
we've got the lake we've got the culture
with a quarry and I think it's a magical
place this is a truly inclusive
experience very special experience but
something that everyone can do I never
businesses will benefit from this I'm
very hopeful and we've already seen
people from all over the world
booking when you come home again to wear
heels Mahler sings Welsh folk songs to
keep up Dylan spirits before the launch
but he needn't worry the courses safety
has been analyzed and tested by experts
however high winds can present a danger
to riders at the end of the course
Taylor gives Dylan Hughes a few tips
before he starts
you need to brief we have people go down
who door up breathe you can breathe
you're gonna reach speeds of 90 100
miles per hour and we make sure you
still happy the person is still happy
because this is quite a dramatic thing
they're gonna be doing yeah I am happier
I just wanna call no ya office the winds
seem to have picked up here can you give
me an accurate reading please of wind
speeds directions and the last gust
please all the last two minutes wind
conditions have changed suddenly if it's
blowing faster than 32 kilometers an
hour he'll have to wait hello it's 20 20
miles per hour southeast and it's 15.3
over the last 10 minutes all clear it's
a fast trip soon after the start riders
hit about 140 kilometers per hour often
the slate outcroppings are only a few
meters below
but by the time the riders are over the
lake the trip becomes a bit calmer
fifty-five seconds later it's all over
in that short time Dillon has made a
descent of 400 vertical meters
absolutely brilliant brilliant you
coming down and you just rip of the
slate and then I you just go over the
cliff line and we just Oprah's on all
our swivel a fantastic look place just
opens up beneath you and it feels like
you just fly you feel on top of the
world a ride on Europe's longest zip
wire costs just over 50 euros the owners
are sure that once riders have
experienced the trip they'll be back
you